- Whenever people come together to work,
you can be sure that
at some point in time,
there's going to be a
problem that comes up.
Some conflicts will arise and sooner
or later you will be in
a position that you need
to solve these kind of
critical situations.
This is a challenge for many people,
especially for young professionals.
Many people don't want
to confront other people face to face,
they would rather prefer harmony
and not needing to put
themselves out there
to have these difficult conversations.
But of course,
these difficult
conversations are important
and often just needs to take place
and during my time as a
consultant at McKinsey,
I learned a simple
principle that was aimed
to guide young consultants in how
to confront clients how
to handle challenging
and sensitive situations at work.
Oh, hey, Hello everybody and welcome
to another coffee break
with Firm Learning.
My name is Ian Rinchen on this channel.
I want to help you be successful,
in the first years of your career,
doesn't matter if you're a young,
professional or recent graduate,
that will enter the workplace soon.
If you're taking any value
out of this video at all,
please press the like button
for the YouTube algorithm.
And also subscribe to this channel
and also hit the notification bell
to stay informed on
all the future content,
I have planned out for you.
I will release at least
one video every Saturday.
So stay tuned for that.
Inspiration for today's video
I got on a conversation,
that was going on on my Instagram Channel.
In the last days I posted several pieces
of content on how you can actually handle
and address difficult
and sensitive situations,
that you might face in your work.
And after that I received
messages from any
of you sharing situations
that you are facing
in your work environment
or even also in your private life.
And then we were having a discussion on,
what you can actually do
in your specific instance.
And adjust from it that
I like to share here
because I believe that many
of these problems are very much about,
how you actually confront
the other person,
and what ways of
communication you use in order
to make sure that you are
addressing the problems,
in the right way.
So as you can imagine,
there are many reasons
why in the workplace,
you might find yourself
in a sensitive situation.
It could either be,
that maybe you have an
argument with a client,
he might be unsatisfied,
with how you resolve a specific instance,
in your relationship.
And there might be an issue,
that you would like to solve.
Or at least as likely
there might be a colleague
of yours whom you have
a disagreement with,
on a personal or work related topic.
And now you're looking for a way
to resolve this kind of situation.
Whenever there are people involved,
it's clear that there's
always a big potential,
for problems for drama
for sensitive situations.
And the question is,
how do you actually handle it?
And of course,
this is not only true for
your professional life,
for your work life,
but at least as true for your private
and personal life.
What I see many people
do in these situations
and this is also true for
many associates I work with,
when being a project lead.
People tend to like to write an email.
Whenever there's a problem,
you write an email to send it
to the other person.
And this is the way of communication,
that just many people choose.
And there seem
to be some rather
obvious reasons for that.
First of all,
it's very often the easiest thing to do.
Wherever you are,
whenever you have the time,
you can just write an email, send it off.
And then from your perspective,
the problem is solved.
At least this is what you think.
And then second, also,
it helps you avoid
these tough discussions,
when you really need
to look somebody in the face.
And having this really hard,
to have face to face discussion,
with another person on a topic,
that might make you feel uncomfortable.
On a topic where you
know that it's an issue,
for the other person,
that you just do not
know how to resolve this.
People have a natural tendency
to avoid these kinds of
confrontation situations.
And just writing an email often seems
to be an easy way out where you can avoid,
this direct confrontation
with your supervisors,
with other colleagues,
with clients or with people
in your personal life.
And many of the messages,
that you sent me on Instagram reminded me
of a prior instance,
when I was a young consultant at McKinsey.
And I was facing such
a difficult situation,
with one of my clients
who I was responsible for.
Now I already sent this
client several emails
and I was sitting in the TeamRoom
and complaining to my project lead saying,
this person is so difficult to work with.
I've already sent him so many emails,
he just doesn't reply
or when he replies is
giving me such a bad time.
I really do not know what else to do.
And this was the moment,
where my project leader
that time taught me one
of the Golden Rules of consulting.
How you interact with colleagues
and clients in this rule
are pretty much three words.
It is walk, talk, write.
Again, the rule is walk, talk, right?
What does it mean how is this rule
to be understood?
Well, it is a rule that is tell you,
how you should handle these kind
of difficult communication situations.
And it gives you the priority,
how you should act.
The first priority that
you should follow is walk.
And with walk,
what is meant here is
that you are supposed
to walk to this person's desk,
walk through your clients,
to your colleagues desk,
and talk to the person face to face.
Try to resolve the situation on a face
to face conversation.
When you look somebody in the face,
you have the best opportunity
to really understand best the
other person's perspective
and come to an agreement that works,
for both sides on the table.
And yes, of course,
it's not always possible to walk
to the other person
and then it might just not be feasible
to talk to the other person face to face.
So the rule again goes, walk talk, write.
So if walking is not possible,
then the second priority
for you is to talk.
So this means that in this case,
you pick up the phone and you talk
to the person on the phone,
in order to resolve it.
And again, while it is a
significant difference,
whether you talk to the
person face to face,
or just on the phone,
talking on the phone,
or maybe on a video conference,
is the second best thing that you can do.
And only if these things are not possible,
if they are not feasible,
then the third option is to write.
Then you can open an email
and write whatever
thoughts you might have.
Though here again, if you
write you might be smarter
to actually then just ask
for phone conversation
or for face to face meeting in order
to blowing out all your steam,
while writing it in an email, right?
So don't be an email warrior.
This is what I mean here.
If you need to write an email,
try to just use it to
have a phone conversation,
especially when the topics
are difficult and sensitive.
And there's really a problem
that needs to be solved.
If you just think about your experience.
How there are you then
resolve the situations.
I hope you agree with me that most
of the time it was due
to face to face meeting
or phone call and not just
by you writing an email.
Even though of course,
I understand that in many situations,
it's just so much easier
to write an email than
to meet the person face to face.
Especially if you know
and expect that the conversation is going
to be a difficult one.
So looking back at that feedback point,
that I received as a young consultant,
for my project lead,
this was really a game changer.
This principle of walk talk, write,
really made a big difference,
in my professional life.
And then when a few years later I advanced
to become a project lead myself,
when I had conversations
with my associates,
and they were telling me,
that they struggled in certain situations.
That they struggled with
interacting with clients,
when then I try to understand,
how they have interacted
with them very often,
the result was that they
relied far too much,
on written communication.
And just did not make an
effort big enough really,
to go out there and talk
to the people in person.
So what are your experiences?
What do you think?
What difficult situations
have you already encountered,
in your professional life?
Let me know in the comments below.
I'd love to hear from you.
You have already experienced
and what your reflections are,
what your insights are into how
to handle these kinds
of difficult situations.
And again, if there's
any value you took out
of this video at all,
please hit the like button,
also subscribe to my channel
and hit the notification bell.
And also, just to let you know,
in the last weeks,
I really reactivated
my Instagram presence.
My Instagram handle is
@FIRMLEARNING as well.
If you'd like to become part
of my Instagram community
join there as well.
At the moment,
I'm pretty much posting new content,
on my Instagram channel
several times a day.
I'm just so grateful
to have all these channels over,
which I can communicate with you.
And we can form just this
big Firm Learning community.
So thank you for being part of it.
I very much appreciate your time.
Thanks for watching again,
I'm Ian Rinchen from Firm Learning
and I wish all of you a great weekend.